Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Paula Motter
El 27 de mayo de 1941,
el buque de guerra alemán 'Bismarck'
se hundió tras una feroz batalla.
Únicamente 118 de sus 2200
tripulantes sobrevivieron.
Pero cuando un destructor británico
llegó al área en busca de prisioneros,
se encontró con
un sobreviviente inesperado:
un gato blanco y negro que
se aferraba a una madera flotante.
Durante los meses que siguieron,
el gato cazó ratas y levantó
la moral de los británicos,
pero un torpedo impactó contra
el casco del barco y lo hundió.
Milagrosamente, el gato sobrevivió.
Recibió el sobrenombre
de 'Sam, el insumergible',
viajó hacia Gibraltar con
los tripulantes rescatados,
y sirvió en otros tres barcos,
uno de los cuales también se hundió.
Finalmente, se retiró a un hogar
para marineros en Belfast.
Quizá muchos crean que los gatos
no pueden ser buenos marineros,
o compañeros serviciales de ningún tipo.
Sin embargo, los gatos han convivido
con los humanos durante miles de años,
y nos han ayudado tanto
como nosotros a ellos.
¿Cómo pudieron estas criaturas
solitarias pasar de predadores salvajes
a oficiales de la marina e
incluso a compañeros de sofá?
La domesticación del gato contemporáneo
se remonta a más de 10 000 años atrás,
a la Media Luna Fértil
a inicios del Neolítico.
El ser humano estaba aprendiendo
a someter la naturaleza a su voluntad,
por lo que se producía
más comida de la necesaria.
Los campesinos del Neolítico
almacenaban los granos sobrantes
en grandes fosas y en silos
de arcilla de baja altura
Pero esta acumulación de alimentos
atrajo hordas de roedores,
como así también a su predador:
'Felis silvestris lybica',
el gato salvaje oriundo de África
del Norte y del sudoeste asiático.
Estos gatos salvajes eran cazadores
rápidos, feroces y carnívoros.
En tamaño y apariencia eran muy
similares a los gatos domésticos actuales.
La principal diferencia
es que los primeros gatos salvajes
tenían mayor masa muscular,
pelaje rayado, y eran menos sociales
con otros gatos y con las personas.
Fue la sobrepoblación
de roedores en los graneros
lo que atrajo a estos animales
usualmente solitarios.
Y a medida que los gatos salvajes
aprendieron a tolerar a las personas
y a otros gatos a la hora de comer,
creemos que los campesinos también
comenzaron a tolerar a los gatos
como control de plagas gratuito.
Tales eran los beneficios
que los gatos migraron junto
a los campesinos del Neolítico
desde Anatolia hacia
Europa y el Mediterráneo.
Las alimañas eran el mayor
problema en alta mar:
devoraban las provisiones
y roían las sogas.
Por ello, los gatos se convirtieron
en muy buenos compañeros de viaje.
A la vez que estos gatos de Anatolia
comenzaban a navegar alrededor del mundo,
los egipcios domesticaron
sus propios gatos locales.
Venerado por su habilidad para
deshacerse de serpientes venenosas,
atrapar aves y matar ratas,
el gato doméstico tuvo un rol
central en la cultura religiosa de Egipto.
Estos gatos fueron inmortalizados
en pinturas, jeroglíficos, estatuas
e incluso en tumbas,
momificados junto a sus amos.
Los gatos egipcios atravesaron el Nilo,
manteniendo a las venenosas
serpientes de mar bajo control.
Y, tras ser promovidos
a barcos más grandes,
comenzaron a migrar de puerto en puerto.
En la época del Imperio romano,
los barcos que navegaban
entre la India y Egipto
transportaban al gato salvaje
de Asia Central, el 'F. s. ornata'.
Siglos más tarde, durante la Edad Media,
los gatos egipcios viajaron hasta
el mar Báltico a bordo de barcos vikingos.
Tanto los gatos salvajes de Oriente
Medio como los de África del Norte,
seguramente domesticados para esta fecha,
continuaron viajando por toda Europa,
y finalmente partieron también
hacia Australia y América.
La mayoría de los gatos actuales
descienden del 'F. s. lybica'
de Oriente Medio o de Egipto.
Pero un análisis más detallado del
genoma y del pelaje de los gatos actuales
nos revela que,
a diferencia de los perros,
que han experimentado
siglos de cría selectiva,
los gatos de hoy son genéticamente muy
similares a los gatos de la antigüedad.
Salvo el haberlos vuelto
más sociales y dóciles,
casi no hemos alterado
su comportamiento natural.
Es decir, los gatos hoy día son
más bien lo que siempre han sido:
animales salvajes, cazadores feroces
que no nos ven como 'sus dueños'.
Y, considerando la larga
historia que compartimos,
puede que estén en lo cierto.